[Music]
foreign
[Music]
attribute the Renaissance of comic book
movies to the likes of DC and Marvel
ranging from successes like Dawn or
Superman to Burton's Batman to Remy
Spiderman to redacted's X-Men but it's
easy to overlook the low budget 90s film
that skyrocketed to success by bringing
a heartfelt fun and faithful adaptation
of the Beloved dark and gritty Indie
comic spawn not just kidding Turtle
Power it's
t-u-r-t-l-e power
t-u-r-t-l-e power
t-u-r-t-l-e power see this beautiful
Ninja Turtles
over the heroes for in this day and age
who could ask for more TMNT spring from
humble beginnings is a parody of grim
and gritty Frank Miller s Comics by two
guys who just like drawing Turtles and
then hit the big time as a wildly
popular animated series and a massive
toy line by Playmates so the next
natural conclusion was to take the
turtles to the big screen because for
some reason we've built up a mentality
that art is valid unless it's a live
action to our theatrically released
movie and all other storytelling mediums
are somehow inferior and it doesn't even
count unless the movie is live action
you think taking the Turtles back to
their slightly dark and gritty Roots as
opposed to the light and colorful world
of the Animated Series would be a huge
risk the target audience for turtle
content became mostly kids watching
Saturday morning cartoons
would getting into the violent and
over-the-top storyline of the comics
alienate them
apparently not because everyone [ __ ]
loved this movie and there's plenty of
reasons to I hadn't seen it in years
before doing this video but I was
shocked just how tightly this script
adapts several issues of the comics back
to back into one cohesive three-act
movie even the Raphael solo issue became
a handful of scenes at the beginning
they didn't have to include Casey Jones
but thank Christ they did because he's a
really cool character and everything
outside of the weird Duke Nukem version
of him from the 80s Show so that's your
game is it we're mine's mudslinging
this guy is starting to get on my nerves
I think without this movie a really
strange warped version of that character
might have stuck around or maybe like he
would have never caught on to begin with
now word from our sponsor special thanks
to today's sponsor established titles
established titles is a Project based on
historic Scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
Lords and Ladies in English they allow
you to buy as little as one square foot
of dedicated land so you can be an
official Lord or lady what would you do
with one square foot of land plant a
tree on it establish titles as a fun and
novel way to preserve the natural
Woodlands of Scotland while helping
Global reforestation efforts your square
foot of land will be on a private estate
in edelston Scotland and you'll receive
an official certificate with a Crest
your certificate features a unique plot
number in which you can see the exact
location of your land and tree
established titles will plant a tree
with every order and will work with
global Charities one tree planted and
trees for the future to support
reforestation worldwide and because
you're a lord or lady you can change
your name to that on documents like
credit cards plane tickets or dating
profiles if you think it'll help your
chances it makes a great last minute
gift I actually got one for my dad and
my sister they even have couple packs
that come with adjoining plots of land
the first 200 people purchasing a title
pack using my link will effectively be
next to my Mendoza family plot within a
few minutes of walking distance
depending on how many of you want to
become our Lord or lady we can build a
little Godzilla Mendoza Kingdom
established titles is actually running
in early Black Friday sale plus if you
use the code gmzilla you get an
additional 10 off go to established
titles.com forward slash gmzilla to get
your gifts now and help support the
channel now back to the video being that
I'm a massive fan of the 2003 cartoon I
feel like this movie informed a lot of
how that show adapted the comics the
voice cast and character designs remind
me a lot of this one too even this voice
for Raphael sort of became the default
instead of the more sarcastic and
underplayed version from Rob Paulson
a Jose Canseco bat tell me you didn't
pay money for this the only concessions
I felt they made in terms of the
characters was making April a yellow
wearing news reporter and giving the
turtles their personalities and color
schemes from the cartoon however these
little touches were important for
Bridging the Gap between fans of the
cartoon and fans of the comic and it
helps to make the turtles more distinct
and likable characters
before you get the wrong idea I don't
dislike the 80s cartoon at all I wore
out the VHS tape of several episodes as
a kid just like the rest of these white
guys
I just think the way it adapted the
characters came dangerously close to
like ruining them forever but then
somehow accidentally made them more
interesting and Transcendent than they
ever could have been because they were
all just like the red angry one
it's a delicate balance that that
cartoon struck and ultimately I'm super
thankful that show contributed all the
things that it did even if I prefer a
lot of the other versions of the turtle
story think of it like the 80s show is a
really good seasoning that makes every
other TMNT thing better you want to
assault these fries but you never want
to just eat salt by itself
speak for yourself I'm Shoveling salt
down my throat right now
one day I'll sit down and finally watch
the entirety of that show to give it a
fair Shake I feel like sometimes I'm too
hard on it because the 2003 Show and The
Mirage Comics rotted my brains too much
maybe I'm a hack and the 80s Turtles is
actually superior but anyway movie
Turtles managed to strike a really solid
Middle Ground between Grim dark schlock
and cartoony toy commercials that makes
it a really impressive movie and the
turtles themselves are so perfectly
handled in this film the way they were
brought to live action by Jim Henson's
Creature Shop with elaborate costumes
animatronics puppeteering and pretty
intense body acting is so satisfying to
see they never feel like actors trapped
in clunky costumes their movements are
natural and comfortable and their faces
are believable and expressive even if
there's some blank and you'll miss it
nightmare fuel when they open their
mouths too wide in some shots after a
while I started to forget these were
guys in costumes and just saw yeah
that's Leonardo hey it's Raphael the
first movie ended up being the last
project that Jim Henson personally
worked on before his passing and the
team behind this movie were incredibly
thankful for his contributions and they
knew they wouldn't have had the same
film without him yeah I went out to
dinner with with Jim
after that and we drove past some movie
theater and we actually saw one of the
ushers come out and at a certain point
he had to tell them that they weren't
going to get in and man we saw the
emotion but what are a set of Heroes
without a villain this movie's take on
the shredder is intimidating cold
cunning and badass instead of the goofy
version of him from the cartoon they
decided to go more Darth Vader route and
it worked out rather than the foot Ninja
being unnamed Shredder loyalists or
exploding robots the Foot Clan are made
up of all the cities Wayward Youth and
troubled teens shredder has been
silently collecting recruiting training
and radicalizing at-risk youth to turn
them into the ultimate unseen criminal
organization
this is played a little tragically and
it often shows that these kids becoming
his soldiers aren't all bad people
they're just lost or struggling to find
a place for themselves we see the son of
April's boss at the news station Danny
getting roped into this gang in the sort
of manipulative rhetoric that Shredder
spews to keep these boys in line you are
here because the outside world rejection
this is your family
I am your father
he may not have a world domination
master plan or a secret doomsday weapon
or a brain and a robot that he hangs out
with or anything crazy like that but he
has the entire generation of New Yorkers
under his thumb and the stakes of this
story come from stopping him from
corrupting anyone else around the same
age as the turtles I like that more
mature take on the Foot Clan and it
makes them feel more unique as an
antagonistic enemy Force than your usual
Stormtroopers or other Army building bad
guy units the other biggest core element
of the movie comes from the turtles
facing the really daunting situation of
potentially losing Master Splinter and
having to guide themselves without him
it Harkens back to that scary feeling
when you're a teenager and you realize
soon you'll be out on your own without
your parents telling you what to do or
where to go at first it can seem
enticing to have that much freedom but
it's also taking away a lot of
familiarity and comfort that you had
when you were younger the idea of being
without their dad is something Splinter
tries to prepare them for and
Michelangelo waves it off when asked
about it by Donnie later and once
they're confronted with that reality
later in the film Mikey's the one who we
see taking it the hardest because he was
in denial of that possibility these
touches make the turtles feel like real
teenagers and that's something I don't
think the cartoon or the comic is
successfully done by this point it's a
story about putting them on the
precipice of adulthood and their bond is
Brothers being the only thing that pulls
them through all that uncertainty in
that time it's what they have that these
other kids in the Foot Clan don't it's a
supportive family keeping them from
falling down the wrong path when they
have to make their own decisions for the
first time the movie is also carried by
its human lead April O'Neil played by
Judith Hogue she has a lot of great
chemistry and interactions with the
turtles and she really feels like their
friend and like she gets them and it
just makes everything feel a lot more
like cozy and fun for the first half and
this version of April also has really
good chemistry with Casey too which like
kind of didn't go anywhere but you know
it was supposed to
share the movie as some kick-ass fight
scenes because they filmed it in Hong
Kong with a few well-trained martial
artists stunning the suits and sure it
has some really awesome puppeteering and
practical effects that still hold up
pretty well but the biggest strength of
this movie was just a really mature and
heartfelt script that took the material
seriously and treated the turtles and
their world like real people rather than
just silly cartoon characters
and then the movie made a [ __ ] zillion
dollars and broke all independent movie
records in its time which only made the
cartoon bigger and then which meant more
toys and then like a bunch of video
games and there's just so much money so
naturally they made a sequel where they
threw all that out the window
immediately things got shaken up with
the cast that makes this movie feel more
disconnected from the first the original
April O'Neil actress Judith Hogue was
let go from the first movie Her theory
was because the producers thought she
complained too much while filming the
first one the new actress for April
really isn't as compelling in the role
Corey Feldman was unavailable at the
time to voice Donnie since he was having
some personal struggles with addiction
they recast Raphael's voice actor with
someone who actually sounds pretty much
the same so I didn't notice until I saw
the cast list and Casey Jones is nowhere
to be found for this whole movie
for some reason we do have a new
character in Kino a martial artist and
pizza delivery guy that ends up bumping
into the turtles and April he's actually
played by Ernie Reyes Jr who is the
stunt performer and body actor for
Donatello in the first movie
apparently the crew and producers loved
him so much they wanted to give him a
human character to play and I gotta
admit he's pretty charming and cool so I
like him being here even though it's at
the cost of Casey like God damn he kicks
ass look at him go
otherwise everything about this movie
feels so tacked on to the first one in a
way it begins with shredder dead and
then ends with shredder dead nothing was
learned or gained the turtles don't
really have any character arcs there's
like a vague attempt at one with them
wanting to explore the outside world
more and then they get to have a party
with some humans at the end but it's
just played as more of a gag than any
kind of growth for them
and remember go ninja go ninja go
I made another funny
this story Loosely adapts the storyline
from the turtle's lore where the secrets
behind the mutagen are revealed the
titular Secret of the Ooze is that
[Music]
uh it's just some industrial runoff
chemicals there's nothing really special
about it in any way they also get rid of
almost all of it that still exists by
the end of the First Act in the comic
The Secret of the Ooze is that it's like
fuel for technology from a secret alien
race that's stranded on Earth and living
among us in Disguise for decades and
building a trans-dimensional teleporter
to bring them back to their own home
planet now that's a reveal
I wonder why Kevin and Peter dislike
this one so much maybe it's because they
removed the whole story from the story
they were adapting
second movie was a huge step backwards
and so we kind of ended up in square one
with the third move the other big issue
is the tone diverting from the first
movie's maturity back to the 80s cartoon
gives you a crazy whiplash when you
watch him back to back what was once
dimly lit dark and grainy is now
colorful and warm lighting just the
change in visuals alone makes this feel
a lot less cinematic
the violence has also been dialed back
so the turtles never draw their weapons
except for Donny you know because he's
got a stick it's all gotten a lot more
cartoonish and safe
the fight choreography is still really
strong but you can tell they're holding
back and it hurts the movie they're
carrying deadly weapons getting
surrounded by enemies and they're
choosing not to use them instead they're
surrounded by safer objects that can
functionally work as the same as their
weapons like
like Mikey hits you with sausages and
yo-yos this time isn't that fun shutter
gets his hands on the one last sample of
Mutagen in the world and his big
Ambitions for them are to make two
mutants that work for him
not Bebop and Rocksteady apparently
Eastman and Laird [ __ ] hate them so
we get Toca and razar who are even
sillier and even dumber
smart move boys
we also have another character who
helped create the mutagen at tgr what
tgr t
huh who looks exactly like the cartoon
version of Baxter Stockman but isn't him
they gave him the bow tie and everything
come on guys if you want this to be more
like the cartoon then why is it not
Baxter and why is this not Bebop and
Rocksteady you decide to ditch the
Mirage stories in favor of the cartoons
contributions but you didn't take
anything from there either
why is this movie filled with nothing
it wants to be sillier and crazier than
the first one but it doesn't want to go
far enough because it doesn't want to
bring in the wacky aliens of the comic
relief villains
just a really Troll and Bland plot that
doesn't commit to anything it's all
halfways
also what was the point of changing tcri
what's the thought process there did
they just want to be different but
couldn't commit to actually making any
decisions
tgri Fridays
this movie just feels really empty and
devoid of any creativity or passion it's
not offensively bad or anything in fact
it's completely watchable but it's just
missing that secret sauce that ooze if
you will that makes it feel like an
actual story worth being told the
costumes fight scenes and voice acting
are all really strong but everything
else feels really weak even the final
confrontation was Super Shredder at the
end feels rushed and sweeped under the
rug as quickly as they can he's too
physically strong for them to beat so he
just accidentally kills himself by being
a big dumb Bruiser and toppling a
building onto his head it's a really
convenient unexciting way to kill off
your main villain considering how
intimidating he was in the first movie
Jacob Jacob wanted to write a part in
here because we were writing this video
together he also drew some pictures for
it I hope you like his pictures he drew
some nice pictures
now as a big fan of the 80s Turtles and
the Mirage Turtles I feel like there's
just a few changes that could have been
made to make this movie a lot more
palatable especially coming off the
first one imagine it this way
replace these guys with these guys
that's it
but seriously all you really need to do
without writing an entirely new story is
just keep Casey around since he fills
the exact same role as Gino he's the
human friend of the turtles who's always
looking for a fight even Splinter is all
like chill the [ __ ] out man violence is
the last resort
like the whole time I was watching the
intro of this movie I was just thinking
about how it'd be so much cooler to open
with a reintroduction of these
characters
the uh
pizza's here
well what does this guy talking about
we guarantee an S kicking in 30 minutes
or less
oh I'm sorry can we get your order wrong
no
why don't you uh take it up with the
managers
[Music]
and if you want to keep Kino that bad
you can just have Casey Jack the pizza
delivery outfit from him and then have
him follow Casey in the Turtles back to
April's Place
alternatively the sentence Jim Henson
makes utroms could have made this
worthwhile
tmnt2 secret of the booze is far from a
terrible movie but it's far from perfect
I don't agree with Eastman and Laird in
their take that it's like the worst one
I think it has some redeeming qualities
and it wasn't too far from being a
decent sequel
but I can see why they as creators of
the turtles disliked it so much
there's no story in the story and it's a
movie with my identity problem that
can't decide if it wants to embrace the
weirdness of the cartoon or stick by the
realism of the original film
so it's just really like
nothing but that movie still made money
despite his problems so they gotta do a
third one Hollywood's a business kids
the poster for this movie tells you
everything you need to know they look
[ __ ] terrible and there's a bad time
travel gimmick
this movie doesn't even look like a real
movie
this feels like a TV movie all this High
key lighting Illuminating just how cheap
and bad the characters look now
it's so bright that they really look
like rubber the darker Lighting in the
original movie helped to hide the
imperfections in the costumes now it's
also obvious and on full display and
these costumes are much worse instead of
the Henson company doing the suits for
the turtles this time they Outsource it
to a company that doesn't have a link on
Wikipedia so you know they were really
prolific and professional instead of
lively and believable marvels of
practical effects that still hold up
pretty well the turtles are now
dead-eyed lifeless and robotic their
eyes blink and react so rarely that they
just feel like costumes
these voice actors are trying so damn
hard to make this work but the lip flaps
look like garbage there's no real
attempt to match the mouths to the words
so they just look like robots chomping
at the air well an imaginary voice from
off-screen Rambles over it
and you you should be having fun it's
also a lot more obvious where the eye
holes are and I can't stop staring at it
it takes me out of the scene I know his
eyes are there so remember that cool
storyline from the comic no you don't
I'll tell you about it Renee the time
mistress steals the scepter that lets
you travel through time and goes on the
run from an all-powerful Cosmic entity
named Lord simultaneous and accidentally
takes turtles on an adventure through
time they end up having to steal the
time scepter back from a horned demon
guy named savante Romero who lives in a
big castle
now just imagine that
but like without all the cool and
interesting parts so they just randomly
find this time scepter by itself and
April is sent back to feudal Japan by
accident she literally finds it off
screen at a flea market before the movie
even starts and she brings it to their
house also the scepter switches you in
time periods with someone else and it
switches your clothes too these guys
should all be naked wearing shin and
elbow pads if you're going to establish
this stupid rule then stick to it Corey
Feldman is back as Donnie in this one
but his voice sounds a little bit more
Gravelly ironically I think the way he
sounds in this one might be better as a
Leonardo voice
whoa somebody's activated the scepter we
gotta go now Rafael has been recast
again so he's had a different voice in
all three movies and Splinter's voice is
different now because his original actor
Kevin Clash was with the Jim Henson
company the newer Splinter voice just
isn't the same he's mostly speaking in
Whispers and it doesn't command the same
level of respect attention
you cannot go without the others it
would be cowardly should have gotten
Mako to do it Casey's back though he
does nothing really useful the entire
movie but he's still funny and I missed
him
how'd your brain and plan go good what
his role in the movie is to just watch
over the five time displaced guys that
April and the turtles switch places with
via time travel
and it has big Bill and Ted Vibes
because he's like taking them to the bar
and then teaching them how to play
hockey and hey hey
hockey mask
Jesus at least in this one there's a
little more going on with the characters
than like nothing at all Mikey and RAF
start to enjoy being in feudal Japan
because people sort of accept their
existence there and they're allowed to
interact with humans and go out in the
daytime so at the end they seriously
consider just staying there and starting
new life since they're sick of being
hidden in the streets of New York sure
your home's a nice apartment my home's a
sewer uh I've been thinking the same
thing Leo people appreciate us here but
there's not really a reason for them to
decide to go home they just do it
because Leo and Donnie say they should
and the conflict doesn't really get
fleshed out as much as it could have
been for a movie called turtles in time
they really don't go to that many time
periods especially after that Kick-Ass
video game happened and it's just
it's just a little lame this one's been
trashed at death and for good reason but
I just find there's not much else to say
it's not really watchable it's super
cringy and embarrassing and tedious and
I don't think this movie should have
been made I guess everyone else agreed
because this one did not make mad bank
like the first two I'm sure there's
someone who loved this movie when they
were like
six
[Music]
what started as a really honest attempt
at adapting the comic devolved into
robotically making these movies because
they just needed to financially
passion and love for the material exited
pretty much right away and I can
understand why so many TMNT fans were
frustrated with this Trilogy growing up
it's before my time yes but I can still
feel that growing disappointment as each
installment passed
but thankfully due to Legacy sequels
made decades later for no reason this is
not where this turtle's timeline ends
and we actually have a fourth movie hey
they got Mako the TMNT 2007 movie wasn't
necessarily marketed as the fourth film
in the series but a lot of little
evidence adds up that it is from subtle
things
to overt references to previous entries
in the quadrilogy you can just accept
that this is the last one I really do
want to advocate for more animated
Legacy sequels if they can't do live
action ones kinda like those two Adam
West Batman animated movies since he was
too old to put the costume on make Ash
vs Evil Dead season 4 is a cartoon why
not but I really love the visual style
of this film The more dark and muted
colors put me off as a kid but today I
appreciate just how unique this looked
compared to so many other animated
movies from the time the turtles
themselves have these exaggerated
proportions that really look just like
they did in the Mirage Comics I I'd say
the only thing I don't like is their
giant Square noses their eyes are a
little too far apart and it just makes
their faces unappealing that's why I
don't want any of the toys from this
movie because they're big stupid Square
noses aside from the turtles themselves
the environments look exactly as I'd
expect Eastman Laird's art style of the
look in 3D
human characters aren't half bad either
except for this one guys mouth sack
he's voiced by Kevin Smith the cast has
changed again and I commend this movie
for doing something that so rarely
happens and theatrically released
animated films they got real voice
actors
they didn't stunt cast some [ __ ]
like Colin Dylan Sprouse as Donnie and
Mikey or get something ridiculous like
Master Splinter voiced by Brian Cranston
doing an offensive accent
this is no one North's wrath James
Arnold Taylor is Leo Mikey Kelly is
Mikey and Mitchell Whitfield as Donnie
all these guys are professional va's
doing the voices for the main characters
and not like
names you've heard of that were famous
for a sitcom or something remember when
movies used to do that
Robin Williams was right to be weary of
Disney Genie ruined everything
accidentally if you think about it Robin
Williams Genie is the reason why Mario
sounds [ __ ] up now but the end result
is that this movie looks and sounds like
professional animation this cast is so
strong and the celebrity voices that
you'd expect like Chris Evans as Casey
Sarah Michelle Gellers April and Patrick
Stewart as the villain they don't
detract from the film either they're all
more normal and human characters so more
toned down vocal performances fit them
well enough
while the more lively expressive
performances fit the turtles since
they're these larger in life Fantastical
creatures with big dramatic emotions and
scenes that's not to say the human voice
actors aren't very expressive or
anything they're all great Chris Evans
especially surprised me before he was
Captain America Superstar Chris Evans I
feel like under the right circumstances
in the right time period and with the
right haircut he could have been a good
Casey Jones in live action too half the
characters he's ever played are already
almost that guy Nolan North and James
Arnold Taylor specifically Elevate this
movie so much with their portrayal of
the complicated sibling relationship
with RAF and Leo the strongest
components of the movie is Leo's story
of leaving home for a year to train in
South America and coming home to find
that his absence has left his family in
a lost and depressive State the dramatic
core comes from Raphael confronting Leo
for leaving Having resented him for it
and also their rivalry stemming from
both wanting to be heroes in very
different ways
Raphael becomes a vigilante and fights
crime at night and sort of a superhero
Persona he's created for himself to hide
from the rest of the family that he's
sneaking out against Splinter's orders
when Leo finds out he confronts RAF for
being irresponsible and going out and
intentionally looking for trouble and it
leads to the best [ __ ] part of the
movie don't do this rap
I'm done taking orders
then there's also some [ __ ] about an
ancient prophecy and five Stone Warriors
and 13 monsters and a 3 000 year old
Knight and also cries there and none of
that stuff is very interesting or well
thought out at all
this feels like one of the most
incomplete scripts I've ever seen make
it to the screen for a movie This Is 40
of a complete idea it's like they wrote
all the awesome Raph and Leo stuff first
and then tried to come up with a whole
movie to go around it but didn't work
nearly as hard on any of that stuff
everything with the family struggling to
move on without Leo is really
interesting and then the movie just goes
on autopilot with everything else major
plot elements feel like you could
totally remove them and nothing would be
different Karai is there for what I
assume is setting up Shredder's return
in a planned sequel look it's this
concept art he's on a poster he would
have been there but not as a quick
post-credits thing she's in the entire
movie and the turtles don't even really
acknowledge she exists
wow good news is there's a bunch of foot
and it's just getting the snot kicked
out of them like the Foot Clan is back
in New York for the first time since the
second movie with an entirely new leader
and the turtles don't even seem to care
no question if she's a friend or an ally
it's really weird on top of that five
Stone Warriors and 13 monsters is too
much [ __ ] to keep track of well one of
the Warriors isn't Stone but his outfit
looks so great may as well be you can
pick one or the other but adding both of
those factions of characters makes for
18 big gray villains that are hard to
remember or care about like yeah great
idea there's been a discussion about big
gray villains in recent years so let's
have a movie where there are 18 of these
[ __ ] guys literally made of stone as
gray as you can get like sometimes I
can't tell the difference between the
stone Knights or the monsters and fight
scenes because their designs are so
indistinct and hard to quickly scan in
combat the plot is that this this guy
named something Winters opened a portal
to the negative zone or whatever and it
made him Immortal but turned his best
Pals to Stone and released 13 monsters
into the world Flash Forward 3000 years
in his evil master plan is to undo the
curse by capturing the 13 monsters
sending them back home allowing him and
his Stone homies to finally die what are
the downsides of this evil plan why is
he the villain
uh the movie forgot to answer these
questions so he's kind of not even the
villain and this movie just has no
antagonist and the conflict doesn't even
really involve the turtles until one of
them gets mistaken for one of the 13
Monsters the turtles just sort of
accidentally see all of this take place
and for the majority they're just
totally indifferent to everything one of
those Stone generals tries to stop
Winters and like keep them all from
dying way too late into the movie and
those guys become antagonists to Winters
but not really to the turtles
like they're not really there for any of
this stuff it's really dramatic and
interesting when your main protagonist
Force are like kind of irrelevant to the
things happening around them this movie
has a lot of really awesome scenes
sprinkled throughout some great art
design and performances but as a whole
It just fits together really confusingly
and it doesn't feel like a cohesive
single idea
just a bunch of random [ __ ] that
happened all around the same time
which is weird because it almost doesn't
even really feel like a complete mess
while you're watching it just kind of
like the movie fell asleep at the wheel
sometimes TMNT 2007 has its problems but
it's still a massive spike in quality
after the Turtles in Time movie part of
me really just wishes this series of
films had a more consistent look tone
and cast
these voice casts have no consistency it
gets even worse with the reboot films
Raphael has a different voice in five
out of six movies
they only managed to keep the same one
for both of the Michael Bay produced
movies and he didn't even like being
there overall I think the turtles have
had a much stronger run in TV animation
for all the shows are really different
but I find all four of them super
enjoyable and interesting in their own
ways and they all have these super
dedicated fandoms the movies start
strong and then Peter out really fast
before a little heartbeat at the end
they struck hard and
fumbled into the night there was concept
art for the sequel to the 2007 animated
film that never came to fruition that
looked interesting but it seems there
were other plans the more Michael Bay
style films are a whole other topic to
cover but let's end by looking forward
to the new animated movie coming out
from invincible and the boys producer
Seth Rogen I'm always open to
Reinventing the turtles in new ways but
part of me Wishes the original storyline
would get a more proper conclusion
it would be a legacy sequel to a legacy
sequel if they ever Revisited this
continuity so that ship has pretty much
sailed but you never know
turtles have a way of persisting as a
franchise no matter what happens
say it again
[Music]
I love being a turtle
[Music]
thank you
[Music]